Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
New York.
Buenos Aires.
Rio.
Lagos.
Marseille, Londres, Hambourg, Tokyo.
Bombay, Dacca, Hong Kong,
Djakarta, Hanoï, Shanghai,
Bordeaux, Nice.
Quatre degrés.
4°C, c’est ce qu’il faut
pour que les habitants de ces villes
menacées par la montée des eaux
voient leurs habitations, sans autre
forme de procès, être englouties.
Il va sans dire que ces villes
de plus de 10 millions d’habitants,
pour celles en dehors de l’Europe,
ne représentent qu’une fraction
des territoires qui seront
et sont d’ores et déjà confrontés
à ce phénomène catastrophique.
New York qui disparaît,
difficile à imaginer.
Pourtant, il ne s’agit ni de prédictions
d’ici à des centaines d’années,
ni de science-fiction.
Les réalités qui commencent
à s’imposer à nous
semblent si éloignées de ce que
nous aurions aimé nous faire croire
que quand le choc se produit,
c’est la panique.
Solastalgie, forme de détresse
psychique ou existentielle
causée par la destruction des habitats,
et par extension,
par le réchauffement climatique.
Elle se rapproche en cela
de l’éco-anxiété.
Première définition que l’on trouve quand
on cherche solastalgie sur Internet -
Wikipedia.
Jean-Marc Jancovici utilise dans
son dernier roman graphique,
« Le Monde sans fin »,
une parabole que je trouve très parlante.
Imaginez, vous êtes
à l’intérieur d’un robot rouge,
flambant neuf d’apparence.
Vous en êtes le pilote.
A l’intérieur, vous ne ressentez plus
ni le chaud ni le froid.
Vous allez vite.
Vous allez très, très vite.
Vous produisez à peu près
ce que vous voulez,
à toute vitesse, vous êtes inarrêtable.
Mais quand vous sortez du robot,
vous êtes déconcerté.
L’expérience était grisante,
mais à quoi marche le robot ?
Quelle est son énergie ?
Qui la produit ?
Quel est son coût ?
Comment le robot a-t-il eu un
impact sur son environnement
et avec quelles conséquences ?
En définitive, ce sont là
toutes les questions
auxquelles répond l’éco-anxieux.
Et à raison,
face à notre modèle de société,
les réponses lui font très peur.
Éco-anxiété et solastalgie,
ce sont des notions qui sont apparues
très récemment dans le langage courant.
Tout comme ces phénomènes sont avant tout
liés à des problématiques récentes.
Mais honnêtement,
je me demande bien qui dans la salle,
face à tous ces constats dramatiques,
ne ressent pas une inquiétude
vis-à-vis de l’urgence.
Bien sûr, je pourrais dire que ma
génération, et moi comme les autres,
nous ressentons tout particulièrement
cette anxiété-là.
Que si le nombre de consultations en
psychiatrie pour les jeunes est si élevé,
c'est aussi pour cette raison.
Ce ne serait pas faux.
La différence étant que nous vivons avec
cette urgence depuis notre naissance.
Mais dans le fond,
est-ce que la vraie question
ne serait pas :
« Comment se fait-il que certains
ne ressentent pas d’éco-anxiété ? »
Est-ce que dans les faits, ce ne sont
pas eux le phénomène marginal ?
Je m’appelle Mattia, j’ai seize ans
et quand je pense trop au réchauffement
climatique, j’ai très très peur.
L’éco-anxiété,
c’est un sentiment que je connais
et qui a commencé à m’animer
il y a déjà de nombreuses années.
J’aurais aimé me rendre compte
plus tôt que je n’étais pas le seul.
Les chiffres me donnent raison.
Selon une étude très récente
de l’OCDE et du Monde,
80% de la population française
est convaincue de l’importance d’agir
contre le réchauffement climatique.
Bien sûr, il reste les 20%,
mais en attendant,
la majorité est du côté de l’action,
de la science, des écosystèmes.
Et ces 20%,
ils n’ont pas moins bien vu le problème,
ils ne sont pas moins en phase
avec les réalités,
ils en sont peut-être tout simplement
à un autre stade de l’acceptation
du réchauffement climatique.
Prenons les choses sous ce prisme.
Vous avez peut-être déjà vu la courbe
du deuil de Elisabeth Kübler-Ross
qui est utilisée en psychologie
lors d’un véritable deuil.
Pour moi, cette courbe est intéressante
parce qu’elle peut aussi
représenter ce qu’il se passe
lorsqu’on découvre
l’ampleur du problème climatique.
Elle représente très bien
mon propre cheminement.
J’ai toujours été
sensibilisé à l’écologie,
mais c’est vraiment quand j’ai eu neuf ans
que je me suis rendu compte
que le problème était réel.
À l’époque, j’étais en CM2 et je recevais
un journal, « Le Petit Quotidien ».
Un soir, j'en ouvre le nouveau numéro.
Des images, beaucoup d’images.
Beaucoup d’images très marquantes
pour qui découvre
que des maisons sont vraiment submergées,
que des populations migrent réellement,
que des forêts prennent feu,
que c’est la vraie vie,
et que tout cela n’a rien
d’une fiction dystopique.
Pendant deux ans, je n'ai plus
voulu en entendre parler.
J’en ai voulu au monde entier
et j’ai été terrifié, puis vraiment abattu
par le poids de la menace
qui semblait planer au-dessus de nous.
Jusqu’à ce que, deux ans plus tard, je me
mette à la vie associative et militante,
mené par une sorte de combinaison
de peur et d’espoir.
J'ai passé de très, très, très longues
heures à organiser des rassemblements,
des manifestations, des créations
d'affiches, de pancartes,
de publications Instagram.
À me soucier de tout.
À avoir peu de reconnaissance
auprès des autres.
À faire de mon mieux.
Qui demanderait cela
à un enfant de douze ans ?
Je l’ai fait parce que je voulais
aller vers ce renouveau,
puis vers cette sérénité.
Et aujourd’hui, je suis toujours militant,
mais d’une façon un peu
différente peut-être,
plus centrée sur mes perspectives d’avenir
puisque j’aimerais travailler dans
le milieu du droit de l’environnement.
Mais revenons à nos pourcentages.
Nos 80% sont convaincus
de l’importance de l’action climatique.
Ils ont déjà fait une partie
du travail d'acceptation.
Ils se situent donc dans la seconde
partie de la courbe, à ma gauche.
Mais les 20%, ils font tout
aussi bien partie de la courbe.
Ils se situent peut-être tout simplement
dans sa première moitié, à ma droite.
Et comment ne pas les comprendre ?
Comment finalement
ne pas nous comprendre ?
Parce que nous aussi,
nous en avons été là.
Nous aussi, nous avons eu ce choc,
fait preuve de déni,
connu ces colères,
ces peurs, ces tristesses.
Certaines nous animent encore beaucoup.
Nous avons simplement commencé
à les transformer en actions,
en tout cas en volonté
de changer les choses.
Et en somme, ce sondage
n’a été fait qu’au début de l’été
et je suis à peu près sûr
que les sécheresses,
canicules et feux de forêt
en ont fait changer d’avis plus d’un.
La situation n'est pas drôle.
En fait, elle n’est même pas
source d’espoir.
Elle est dramatique.
Mais si je devais dire quelque chose
à chacun d’entre nous,
peu importe où nous nous situons
dans la courbe du deuil,
c’est que nous ne sommes pas seuls.
Personne n’ignore ce qu’est
le réchauffement climatique.
Nous savons tous plus ou moins.
Et ça, cette unité-là, qu’on le veuille
ou non, c’est source d’espoir.
Le travail sera long.
Les délais sont courts
et le chantier est énorme.
Mais nous pouvons centrer nos vies
autour de la question climatique.
Nous pouvons orienter nos métiers,
nos choix de vie, nos passions,
autour de cette urgence.
Maintenant, nous devons amener le petit
éco-anxieux qui est en nous plus loin.
Nous devons créer
une nouvelle issue à la courbe :
celle du changement,
celle de l’action,
celle de la reconfiguration.
Montrons à ceux qui pensent que
la solastalgie est un phénomène marginal,
que dans ce cas,
eux-mêmes sont probablement
aussi un petit peu marginaux.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)